ni
最初にまず皆さんかるーく目を閉じてください
これから2つ質問をします
まず
一つ困っていることを思い浮かべてみてください
仕事のことでも家庭のことでも構いません
誰か相談できそうな人はいますか
そしてその人に
力になってほしい
と無邪気に聞けますか
次に
この会場で
お隣に座ってる人の顔を思い浮かべてみてください
初めてお会いした方もいるかもしれません
隣に座っている方は今一つ
悩みを抱えているはずなんです
もし何か力になってあげられるとしたら
立ってあげたいと思いますか
ちょっと困ってるんだけど
助けてくれない
と言われたらどんな気持ちになりますか
目を開けてください
ちょっと隣同士チラチラチラッと目合わせていただいて
笑っていると
わからないですよね
何も言わなければその人が困ってるかどうかなって
からないです
たよるって難しい
でも
やられるって嬉しい
皆さん誰かに頼るときちょっと弱気になったり不安になったり迷惑じゃないかなと思っ
たり
申し訳ないなぁと思ったりされたかもしれません
でも頼られるとなったら
信頼されてるんだこんな私でも何か出来る事あるかもしれないんだ
うれしいちょっと嬉しい気持ちになると思います
とわかっているのになかなか言えないです
なかなか頼めないんです
どうしてでしょうね
私のように地方から都会に出てきて
ホーム端を離れてジエンモー血縁もないところで家族を作っている
核家族が増えています
インターネットがすごく発達してますから
情報は計作成がどんどん出てくるんです
人に聞かなくても頼まなくても web 上で答えが転がっています
それで頼むことがどんどん難しくなりました
これは実は日本だけの問題ではありません
グローバルに見れば先進国どこでも
家族が減り子どもがエリー
二家族がが進み
誰もが頼り合うことが少なくなってきました
その結果として日本では今
年間50万人の人がうつで心を病んでいます
3万人の人が
自殺をしています
20代と30代の死亡原因の第一は自殺なんです
みんな
病んでいても
抱え込んで
助けてと言えずに自ら命を絶っていきました
2011年東日本大震災の直後
私は産婦人科医として被災地に駆けつけました
もともと産婦人科医が少ない東北地方でしたから
何か手伝えることがあるかもしれないと思ったんです
多くの産婦人科のクリニックが流された後一人で頑張っている産婦人科医院の院長先生
がいました
他に起動なくなって妊婦さんが患者さんが訪れるので1日たりともやすめずずーっと
働いていました
過労で倒れそうになりながらも
自分が休むために
人に頼る人の助けを求めるって
やっぱに難しいことだったんでしょう
私はその先生と電話でお話をして
休んでくださいと言いました
地域のために
ご家族のために患者さんのために休んでください
なんとかします
2週間後驚くようなことが起こりました
日本全国から
呼び掛けに応じて15名の産婦人科医が手を挙げてくれたんです
1日だけあるいは2日だけでも休みをとって
週末
夏休み
当直をしに行ってくれました
助けに入った私たちでしたが実は私たちの方が
自分の優しさを引き出してもらえて
被災地の患者さんにそして院長先生に産婦人科医としての使命を感じさせてもらえて
そして勤務先も
経験年数もん出身大学も
違う産婦人科土居同士が出会うことができたんです
このネットワークは今院長先生のお子さんたちの世代も巻き込んで
被災地を中心とした新しいネットワークになっています
仲間の1人が最近
産婦人科医が少ない被災地で新しくさんは神会員を立ち上げました
それもこれもすべて院長先生が
たよってくれたおかげでした
たより i 社会は新しいチャレンジができる社会です
一つ何かのきっかけで誰のもと
それまで一人で頑張ってたのが嘘のように新しい展開が生まれます
そしてあなたが誰かに頼む
そのことであなたが頼んだ誰かに何かあったときその人はきっとあなたに頼みやすく
なるんです
私のエネルギーが水俣私の情熱の源は
産婦人科医としても母親としても新しい命の誕生です
これが私のチャレンジです
私は働きながら子どもを見ながら育てながらやりたいことをやる
これをたくさんの人の力を借りて
行ってきましたたくさんの人に力を貸してもらえたから
たくさんの人が助けてくれたから
5人の子供を育てられたと思っています
無我の中で
やみくもに手探りででしたけれども
たくさんの人の力があったからこそ
育ててこられました
皆さんのチャレンジは何ですか
皆さんにも切っとパッションの実はもっととなるような
心を傾けていつか絶対やり遂げたいと思っているような
鍵かそういうチャレンジがいい
あるはずです
その時に他の人の力を一つ加えてみてください
あなたが誰かを頼ることで
あなたもチャレンジはみんなのチャレンジになります
あなたが誰かいい
助けで手伝って力になってほしい
そういうことであなたの夢は他の人を巻き込んでみんなで喜びを分かち合えるような
大きな目標になります
そもそも
頼むことがチャレンジなんだよっていう方もいるかもしれません
でもそんな方のチャレンジは私は心から応援しています
ご静聴ありがとうございました
me